c'est ici il ya 66 ans dans cette maison
jean monnet rédiger la déclaration
historique que robert schuman à les
adresser à l'europe le 9 mai 1960 un
symbole de l'origine de l'union
européenne qui est venu visiter harlem
désir pour célébrer la fête de l'europe
jean monnet a inventé ce qu'est devenue
la commission européenne sur une haute
autorité a qui ont délégué un certain
nombre de pouvoirs et c'est de là que
sont nées toutes les autres politiques
urbaines la politique agricole commune
le marché commun la politique du
commerce etc
et puis finalement la monnaie commune et
l'europe que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
au programme visite de la maison avec
l'association jean monnet et membre du
parlement européen une fête de l'europe
qui intervient dans un contexte
particulier où l'union européenne
rencontrent des difficultés face aux
grandes crises économiques et
migratoires
il faudra que ceux qui croient à l'idée
européenne ne se laisse pas intimider
par les populistes par les anti
européens par les nationalistes et
proposent au contraire de renforcer
cette maison commune parce que si on la
renforce pas effectivement elle paraît
inefficace et à ce moment là on alimente
encore plus le scepticisme est donc si
on veut répondre au mieux aux grands
défis de l'économie de l'emploi mais
aussi de la sécurité de la crise des
réfugiés
c'est au contraire par davantage de
coopération européenne comptera y est
c'est ça qu'ils vendent
après la visite le secrétaire d'état a
fait face aux élèves du lycée hélène
boucher de tremblay en france le
parlement
la politique une véritable conférence de
presse menée par des adolescents qui
avaient soigneusement préparé leurs
questions balaiera pour fêter notre
c'est notre futur en fait on n'a pas que
comme par exemple le ministre lui il
avait pas pensé
il avait pas pensé à lui pas sa
génération mais la penser aux
générations futures
donc c'est tout comme nous en fait on a
pensé aussi à notre génération figure de
plus tard en fait on danse à avoir oui
la maintenance et nous ils ont fait pour
nous et nous on va faire pour les autres
pour illustrer ses propos le secrétaire
d'état a ensuite été convié à la
plantation d'un arbre avec les lycéens
un symbole de cette construction commune